All right, let's pray. By the way, go to
Uman and say, "Hey, he's live. Here's
the link. Come and join him. Go say,
"Hey, he's live. Why don't you come join
him?" He's foaming at the mouth like his
prophet Muhammad that burning because he
got called out by Patrick David. It was
all set up. We were going to go there
and he ran like Aisha did like a little
girl to his dolls. And now because he
got humiliated and exposed by Patrick
David, he's been trying to save face. if
he was serious about a debate, he
doesn't assign dates and tell us you
better show up. So I did one better and
I called his bluff. So let me give you
receipts again. Notice every Muslim that
said I was scared. When the Lord Jesus
delivered them into my hands, I
humiliated them, crushed them, muzzled
them like they are because I will end
their careers by the power of the Lord
Jesus Christ, Muhammad's God and
destroyer like Jesus ended their
Muhammad's life in glory to you, Father.
Glory to you, Lord Jesus Christ. Glory
to you, Holy Spirit. So, just to show
you that he's a dog trying to save face,
but you guys are too stupid. You fall
for it.
That's not my fault. But I already
called out his bluff. Here, let me get
your receipts.
I already called out his bluff. There
you go. Do I need to teach you guys
you're not demis?
As long as you have the freedom, expose
them
until you can't because they'll try you.
Here you go, man.
Right here.
Tell him to come join my live. I'll give
him the Streamyard.
Here. And I tagged him. I I tagged Porky
Pig and standing for truth. And I'm
going to show you the voice text that I
sent.
Standing for truth. Watch here.
Ramir, let me read it for you. Here's
the link. Take it easy. You are going to
get to pray in marri because people
cannot stop manifesting. Pray God reign
me in. But sometimes the old Sam has to
show up. But notice it's a more cleaner
Sam. I'm just saying prostitute now and
dogs. Right.
So here you go. Since shake porky pig
aka fake ketchup boy aka Muhammad wipes
stealing Oman Iban photo official tagged
him trying to save face after running
away like Aisha from debating on the PBD
by pretending to really want to debate
while giving specific deadlines like
Muhammad Ajab did. To do so I'm going to
call out Muhammad and Porker's bluff.
I've contacted Stanny for Truth
Ministries. I'm going to show you my
voice text on Facebook Messenger. I just
got done telling him now and he has
agreed to host a debate between Shake
Porky Pig and I on his channel now.
Instead of foaming at the mouth and
barking out deadlines, we'll see if
Shamu the Stone Licker is really mad
enough to debate me mono emano on a
neutral platform. Right? He was too
scared to do Patrick but David. So I go,
I propose that Miss Piggy and I begin
with the Islamic dilemma since I will
use his own prophet P R O Fi T because
he's only about prophet to confirm the
Bible to then his
from the that very Bible that Muhammad
confirms. Now tell Muhammad and Miss
Piggy to accept the challenge once
standing for truth ministries emails
him. Lord willing, we should be able to
do it sometime after first week of
January. Now tell Katcheta Boy I'm
calling out his boss. Now someone make a
clip out of this because now we're going
to see if he's going to accept the
debate on a neutral platform because
here you go. Donnie standing for truth.
See I bring receipts homie. Homie don't
play that.
That's why they don't like me. And if
they can, they'll try to put our lives
in the hands of God Almighty, in the
hand of the Father and of the Son, our
God and Save Lord Jesus Christ, the Lord
Jesus Christ, and the hand of the Holy
Spirit, the one true God. But here you
go. I'm going to play it now. Remember
how Daniel Pikachu was barking like a
dog, saying I was running. How long did
he last in that debate? By the power of
the Lord Jesus Christ, by his power, by
the power of the Holy Spirit, I will end
their careers like Jesus ended.
Just let him show up. But here, I bring
receipts. Holmes,
let's get this out of the way. Here you
go. Am I lying? Homie, don't play that.
Here you go, Donnie of Standing for
Truth. Let's play what I sent him.
Here you go.
There you go. Right here. Let's play.
Donnie, if you can also do me another
favor
is barking like a dog because he ran
from debating us on Patrick David and
tell him Sam is willing to debate you on
my channel. He wants to do December
30th. Obviously not
far reach out to him. Tell him, "Hey,
Sam is calling out. Let's debate on your
channel, Standing for Truth." And
obviously it's not going to be one-sided
where he chooses a topic so I can Jesus
buried his daughter.
Okay. Then I reached out to him again.
Watch here.
Tell him mono immano him and I
one-on-one. There's the channel. Let me
know what he says. The fat porker. Okay.
Now, guess what? And then he says,
"Okay, I will, brother. This will be
good because it can be a 2026 debate
challenge to all Muslims. Well,
worthwhile Muslims like these guys.
Perfect. I'll be catching up on emails
over the next few nights as I set up
events for 2026. And so I'll reach out
to both of them because I'm challenging
two different Muslims, Miss Piggy Otman
Fibben Faruk and another Muslim who
thought he can refute to the Islamic
dilemma a scholar. If they deny, I'll
show you and we can let everyone know
they're running. Then I said, "Can I
make a post calling out Porky Pig saying
you will host it?" And he gave me
permission and I did. That was the post.
So ah tonight I just sent him this. Oh,
really? Today? Look,
>> Johnny, let me know when you reach out
to that guy with mine cuz I don't want
him think that he's going to get away
with coming up with deadlines cuz
supposedly on the 30th he wanted to
debate to make excuse uh for running cuz
I want you to bring him on and do the
same thing I did with Daniel.
conversations on him so I can destroy
him and obliterate him in debate less
than 10 minutes. Let me know if you
reach out to him and let me know if he
accepts. Say it's me and him only him
and I. Now watch this here today. Did I
see you got my message homes? He's live
right now because like a dog he's trying
to save face. uh because he ran from PDD
PBD and PBD patch David exposed them and
I played the clip showing he ran because
we had agreed to go on there. I was
gonna
but
now that he got humiliated the Muslims
were complaining. He's now setting
deadlines. First it was December 25th
and he knows we're not going to do it.
Now December 30th on his channel and he
knows we're not going to do it. So he's
going to use that to say see they ran.
So, brother, reach out to him and say,
"Hey, Sam, reach out to me." One-on-one
debate conversation like we did with
Daniel. I'll be moderating. Let's do it.
I'm available uh uh [clears throat]
the week after the first week of
January. So, set it up, man. Call him up
cuz I want to call his bluff to tell him
that he's scared. And that's why he
wants to hide behind his own channel.
Okay?
I'm the one running, right? You think,
man, I run, I'd have an eight pack right
now,
right?
There was no agreement. Ishue, he did
that like Muhammad Ajab. Remember
Muhammad Ajab when I PBD? He said, "I
better call in uh on a Tuesday when I on
Monday when I was flying out."
All right. So, guys, clip this. Sam
Shimon calls. It's going to be him and
I,
right? Him and I. Let's see if he's
manov. He won't have to hide behind his
uh the m the dress of his wives like
Muhammad used to hide in Aisha's m. So
what's up beautiful? You want it? It's
right here. Yeah, this is you. So you
can remember with Jakar. You should see
Jesus how much he blessed me. These two
girls are so beautiful. My oldest one is
5'9. She's almost as tall as me. And the
other one's 5'4. She's getting there.
And they're going to pray for me I get
skinnier by January. Right. Keep it.
>> That's yours? Yeah. So she's keeping the
jakar. Why do you want to keep it?
Because it remind you of me.
That's right. Love my girls.
The best girls in the world, man.
Anyway, so
there you go. Stop bothering me
about this guy. He's a joke because he
had his opportunity. He ran and he's
trying to save face. But you Christians
are the ones that get me upset because
you're ready to pay Jiza because you're
dimmies.
You are what we call useful idiots. Why?
Because you're so stupid and naive that
you fall for the tricks of the Muslims
and then I got to cuss you out. Are you
that stupid to fall for their tricks?
Here we come with receipts. Why didn't
he say yes? Patrick was about to fly me
out. And
God logic. Sorry, brain freeze. And who
said no, I'm flying out? Here we go.
Receipts.
>> Yes, I'm here with a guy named Uman. If
I'm saying the name correctly, he would
like
>> That's Eddie of the D. I'm here with a
guy named Uman. If I'm saying the name
correctly, he would like to come on
since you had him on. He'd like to come
on and have a conversation. I said,
"Okay." So, let me call Sam and see what
I can do. So, I call Sam Shamon and Sam
says, "Absolutely." But he says,
"There's no way they're going to do it."
>> Look, I'm a prophet. I'm more a prophet
of than Muhammad. I said, "They're not.
They're going to back down.
He now has to save face from the
Muslims. Notice he chooses the date and
it's got to be on a Muslim platform. No,
we're going to do it on neutral
platform. It's not my YouTube channel
and it's not yours. It'll be Donnie. Can
you get any fairer than that?
Any fairer than that?
Now, let's finish it. I go, he's not
going to do it now. Patrick David like
and then he goes, yeah, they're like
definitely afraid of him. Look,
>> he's going to cancel if they find out
I'm coming. And then he says, "But why
don't you tell them if Eddie and Usman
are coming in, let me bring a guy named
Avery. I don't know who Avery is."
Vinnie automatically says, "I know
Avery."
>> He's he's a beast.
>> Yeah. Vinnie says, "I know Avery." And
then this guy says this, and this is
when I had to call Eddie. And then, by
the way, they they're like, "Then I get
on a call. It's me, you, him, and
Eddie."
And when he found out it's Eddie and
Avery like well why don't we just do it
me and you and you know why don't we
just do I said no if you're going to
have a debate because it started off
with Sam.
>> See man said why don't just you and me
and you.
>> I already called Sam Sam already agreed.
I'm going to fly him out.
Uh uh uh let's let's have the conver. No
well I have to fly out anyways. Well I
said if I would have changed it you
would have came but I have to fly. Well
let's just do it another time. Oh,
>> and then the next
>> notice he goes, if I were to change it,
meaning if I said let you come in the
studio, you wouldn't have flyed out that
day. Convenient. Now you got to fly out,
but you wanted to be on my show and just
preach your Islam. See,
>> next day this video is played and I call
Eddie. Rob, if you want to play this
clip, whatever, PB&D, whatever he is,
right?
>> Yeah. Let's call you out right now. All
right. Somebody send this video to him.
>> If you're honest, then bring
me anybody else any Muslim die and give
us the same time the same way by
ourselves on your platform
you want to be true and me and Eddie
were supposed to go on there against
Wilbur he picked and he backed out
>> he backed up
of having me because he was [music]
saying
yeah another brother went on with Eddie
actually on two other brothers. Daniel
and Jake went on, right? But the reason
that they watched me on because they
said you cannot attack them. You cannot
attack them.